what do you think is the greatest human
skill not habit but mindset and skill I
think the ability to manage your own
mind and emotions is probably one of the
single most important and maybe the
second is the ability to influence
others that's what makes you a leader
and hopefully you're doing that for a
higher good because there are all kinds
of leaders as you know I don't think
most people are very good at emotional
Fitness most people are just not as
happy as they could be and I did one
book money Master the game it's kind of
like this only and what I did in that
case is I interviewed 50 of the smartest
Financial people play dalio Carl icon
Warren Buffett and out of 50 of them and
I spent a lot of time with them some
have become really good friends there's
probably four or five that are really
happy people oh money makes people
unhappy you know money has nothing to do
with money money makes you more of what
you are just magnifies if you're mean
you have more to be mean with if you're
kind you have more to give you know but
I think that most people are just they
haven't learned to manage what's going
inside doesn't matter how much abundance
they have they're still in apple we've
all seen people that great comedians
that have killed themselves and it's
like they had everything except they
didn't Master what's going on here and
here hey it's Evan Carmichael and I make
these videos because when I started my
first business I really struggled to
believe myself I was making 300 bucks a
month and quit on my business partner
and the thing that saved me was watching
the stories of successful entrepreneurs
they gave me strategies as well as hope
and belief that just maybe I could do it
myself as well and I hope that this
video here today helps you get a little
bit more belief in yourself because I
still need the videos for myself today
too so today let's help you develop the
millionaire mindset enjoy
so I think that skill set is the most
important one that's why even in the
book my last two chapters are making the
most important because it's really about
the power of the mind because like
everybody knows about placebos right
they only discovered in World War II and
it was discovered by accident this
doctor ran out of morphine and he's
treating these these people that are
badly injured and you know you need the
morphine not just so they're out of pain
but so they don't go into shock and the
actual person who discovered this gets
no credit was a nurse because the nurse
hand him a syringe and said we've got
some more morphine so he believed it and
he said you'll be out of pain in just
less than a minute injected them and in
every case none of them went into shock
90 of them were out of pain and they
used nothing it was saline right so
after World War II he went back to
Harvard and he was the person that
created what we now considered being the
double bind studies which are always
compared to a placebo right and but most
people don't know is the bigger the
placebo intervention the more powerful
the Mind believes it so a small pill is
less effective than a big pill an
injection is more powerful than a pill
in terms of its Effectiveness the most
powerful is a is a sham surgery
um the the Veterans Administration did a
study and they did on people doing knee
surgeries and they took one-third of the
people and they just cut them open and
mysticize them and so the backup did
nothing A year later this group the
group that had no surgery had the least
amount of pain the most amount of
flexibility most about it so they
stopped funding those surgeries give you
an idea but that's how powerful it is
and so when you it's even more than
Harvard did a study where they took
barbiturates
babies big red pills and said this is an
amphetamine you need to prepare your
body because you're going to speed up
eating him something fake they give him
an actual drug that slows the body down
and the body sped up so most people
don't understand the power of the mind
and so what I've tried to do is show
people even in this book here are the
things that you can do to take control
of your mind because if you take care of
your body and then you don't take care
of your mind and emotions you can be
miserable rule number two is used at 95
5 rule with Tim Ferriss operate by the
95.5 rule uh 95 of of everything we do
in business if we're doing anything is
right so look for the five percent uh
you didn't find the five percent this is
so powerful and reading it in the book I
was like okay here we go so how do you
spot the five percent how do you know
what five percent matters how do you
prioritize how you attack that five
percent okay well let me just say this
okay I walked into this studio okay and
and I've done a lot of interviews and
and uh as soon as I walk in your your
people greet you they introduce you know
this you come up here here's uh here's
some snacks there's even a a camera
light so if they're doing your makeup up
there it's a perfect lighting uh you I
could tell this guy has his act together
this this guy I'm having a hard time
finding his five percent because they're
doing everything right and I'm not just
saying that but you know everything I'm
saying is true that you have somebody
meet us outside we're not working around
lost and and uh you so I hadn't found
the five percent here I'm sure before
the show's over I will but but it's
there for sure I think you're right
everybody has it but I judged you you
and your operation the second I walked
in and it's no different if I'm pulling
up to a retail store or a hotel or a
restaurant or whatever and before I get
to the front door I'm pulling up in that
parking lot is the parking lot in pretty
good shape are there weeds out there are
there cigarette butts in the parking lot
uh or their lights burn out uh the front
door's got a bunch of smoke judges on it
I haven't even walked in yet and I can
tell you this isn't a crisp operation
I can tell you everything how the
operation is going to be inside before I
ever walked in the front door because if
they're not taking care of the outside
the inside's not going to be good and
that's the same parallel that I used for
the basketball team we had a great year
again we won the most games we've ever
won in a two-year period in my first two
years of ownership but I sat down with
the general manager and the and the head
coach and my top basketball people and
said all right we did 95 percent of
everything right but we didn't beat
Golden State again so let's what do we
need to do how do we improve that five
percent and we kicked it around and and
and that's when we decided that maybe
there's an opportunity to be a little
more athletic and getting a great
transition player who can Speed the game
up and make us a better team like a
Russell Westbrook and so that was the
five percent we were looking for
changing out a few coaching positions
changing out a few other players you're
never going to be great if you don't
look for the five percent rule number
three is be dedicated to learning with
Brian Tracy the next key is to dedicate
yourself to lifelong learning now what
takes you from Rags to Riches is
personal development personal
professional development in the 21st
century as Peter Drucker says knowledge
and skill are the keys to the 21st
century and the only thing that will be
relevant the only skill that will be
relevant in the 21st century is the
ability to learn new skills because
virtually everything you know is
becoming obsolete at a rapid rate
Stephen Covey says that your current
knowledge base has a half-life of two
years which means that half of
everything you know will be irrelevant
within two years and two years from now
half more so if you're not continually
learning and upgrading your Knowledge
and Skills you're not staying in the
same place as Pat Riley says the
basketball coach says if you're not
getting better you're getting worse if
you're not constantly learning you're
actually falling behind so here are the
three keys to continuous learning number
one is read in your field 30 to 60
minutes each day in other words turn off
the television turn off the radio put
aside the newspaper and just read in
your field the very best places to read
by the way are books read books the
best-selling books written by the most
successful people in your field because
books contain a wealth of riches that
can enable you to function at a far
higher level to get much better results
than you than you could before so read
30 to 60 minutes a day I've had people
tell me countless people over the years
that reading an hour a day has doubled
and tripled their income within a year
the second thing you do is take every
course that you possibly can the the
courses and seminars that are available
to you in your field that are given by
professionals that are courses that have
been developed over years and years and
years they have been tested and tested
and tested the person who is talking to
you for several hours has spent
thousands of hours learning their
subject they have dry tested this or or
done test runs with thousands of other
people when you take a course you can
can learn enough information in one or
two days more than you could learn in
two or three years or maybe even a
lifetime all distilled and put together
people say I can't afford a course you
cannot afford not to buy books you can't
afford not afford not to go to courses
some years ago I had a dentist and he
was a very successful dentist I was
recommended to me by a friend and this
status retired at the age of 53 and just
before he retired he sold his practice
for about two million dollars just
before he retired he told me why he said
about that eight years before he had
attended a dental Congress in Hong Kong
he's from this is from California it
flown all the way to Hong Kong to attend
this International Dental Congress
because there were Specialists giving
private lectures sort of plenary
sessions on the side and he attended
this session and it was on a particular
technique of cosmetic surgery that this
dentist had developed that no one else
knew where you could basically
straighten out a person's entire front
jaw so they looked beautiful at a very
low cost at a very high level of
Effectiveness he came back and he began
implementing this in his practice people
began flying from 500 a thousand miles
away every dentist sent their families
members and themselves to this dentist
he was able to charge whatever he wanted
to charge he said eight years later
retired as a self-made millionaire at
the age of 53 who enjoy his money for
the rest of his life from what he
learned from one session at one
convention at one course now that's that
is a true story and maybe it's an
exception but you can never tell where
the information is going to come from
the third way that you can upgrade your
skills is listen to audio programs in
your car
the average driver drives to a 500 000
hours a year twenty five to fifty
thousand miles if you listen to audio
programs in your car according to the
University of Southern California you
will get the equivalent of almost
full-time University attendance just
listening to learning material as you
drive around it can totally and
profoundly change your life very very
important
here's an interesting point the more you
commit yourself to becoming the best
person you can be the more you like
yourself and respect yourself the more
energy you have the bigger goals you set
for yourself the more you persist when
you invest in yourself and you read and
learn and upgrade your skills you're
telling yourself wow I am a person with
a great future and it's up to me to
maximize my potential and your
self-esteem goes up your self-respect
goes up your sense of personal Pride
goes up and you started to get promoted
more and and paid more in in every part
of your life well the next is to develop
a workaholic mentality in our society
today all these people talking about
take it easy have balance in your life
relax Lean Back have fun at work happy
happy get along with your co-workers
this is loser talk loser loser loser now
there's a time in your life when you can
back off all right you can take it easy
but that's when you've made it not
before you've made it because before
you've made it you're in a competition
with hundreds of thousands of millions
of other people like at the Olympics so
all also want to make it and in order
for you to win you are going to have to
work harder and work better and work
smarter than they do so the rule is to
develop a workaholic mentality what does
this mean it means that you start a
little earlier you work a little harder
and you stay a little later use what I
call the 40 plus formula the 40 plus
formula says that working 40 hours a
week
gets you survival and that's all you
work 40 hours a week to survive you make
no progress you don't go ahead you just
barely hang on every hour that you
invest in your work or yourself over 40
is an investment in your future so you
can tell what your future is going to be
with unairing accuracy by looking at how
many hours over 40 you put in now how
many hours does the average self-made
millionaire in America work until he
passes the million dollar Mark 59. some
of them work 70 80 90. the average is 59
hours how much does the average top
executive work 59 hours so that's rule
number one is the hours you put in over
40. people say well my office is locked
and I can't get in more than 40 hours a
week then good then spend the rest of
the time investing in yourself getting
better at your work when you do do it
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special a free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four is globalize your
business with Jack ma we think
globalization anti-globalization and to
trade and trade protection is a problem
it's going to be a big problem in the
future so how we can help globalized we
think globalization is a great thing
and how but you know it's only like a 20
30 years in the past 20 30 years
globalization helped a lot of developer
countries helped a lot of big companies
so in the past 30 years globalization
global trade was controlled by 60 000
big companies
and which make rich company richer big
company bigger and small companies small
countries smes or in trouble and the
young people didn't have a chance so we
think about if we can make globalization
International Trade cross-bought trade
more inclusive making sure every small
business has the chance making sure
every young people has the chance that
we can solve a lot of problems people
worry about the job jobs
because the new technology come will
take away a lot of jobs but I what we
think if we can make globalization more
inclusive then we can create more jobs
if if a small business you can only sell
your products to your neighbors in your
county what if you can sell products
across the ocean across the country to
the others that might be a great
solution for the job of creation and the
great solution for today's problems so
that is why we've been focused we
believe that we can do something for
globalized trade for globalization we
were helping not 60
000 big companies we can help six
million or 1660 million small business
that they can sell and buy across board
this is what we want to do
and the second thing is that the world
economies never be sustainable how can
we make our technology to enable the
global trade Global business to be more
sustainable and meanwhile how we can
make business people and people of the
Next Generation happy and healthier so
these are the three values three
problems that we want to solve the world
is not
globalization people don't like it but
we think we should make it inclusive we
should make Global business more
sustainable we should make the people in
the future a more happy and healthier so
these are three problems and these are
three values we want to create
so in this way that we definitely want
to be a globe a company that can help
globalization so e-commerce will be the
best solution and if you want to do
e-commerce you definitely have a good
technology good people people with good
Vision rule number five is invest in the
right people with Kevin O'Leary what
would you say are a couple of qualities
that you really look for when you're
when you're looking to invest in someone
or when someone has an idea and you
whether you invest them or not you're
like this person is going to be
successful whether it's in this thing or
something else what are those two or
three qualities that all of them seem to
have in your mind whether it be a
leadership skill or
uh Clarity what would that be I I prefer
to invest in entrepreneurs that have
failed once or twice before that have
felt the sting of failure and have you
know gone down the road and and not had
success the first time because their
motivations are completely different
than a more arrogant first timer that
thinks everything they do is going to
make 100 million dollars it's just not
doesn't work that way and so that's one
thing I love there's three things you
have to have the ability to do and know
if you're going to be successful in
business number one is you have to be
able to articulate your idea in 90
seconds or less explain to me why
anybody would want that product or
service and if you take more than a
minute and a half
you're never going to be successful
you're just not and number two is you
have to be able to explain why you're
the right person to execute on that idea
in other words what is it about you that
knows how to take this idea which good
ideas or Diamond doesn't executional
skills are really hard to find so what
is it about you that can execute on this
business and make it work I mean those
two together start to be really
interesting because then as an investor
looks at it says well I'm going to
mitigate my risk I got a great
executional you know expert here and
I've got a great idea and then lastly
the one that I think you have to have a
good command of you have to know your
numbers you have to be able to explain
gross margins market share Break Even
analysis how many competitors how fast
can you grow if you don't know your
numbers you deserve to burn in hell and
I'll put you there myself because you
you really those are the three things
that define success and and I think you
know that's who I want to invest in
someone who has to command of all three
of those that's probably got more than a
50 chance of being successful if they
can do that right on rule number six the
last one before some very special bonus
Clips is become resourceful with John
azerath finding your resources there are
four areas that I want you to
consistently focus on this is what I
teach all of my students I've got over a
hundred thousand students okay who are
learning how to win the game of money
how to change their brain to change
their income change their brain change
their business change their brain change
their lives so number one
I want you to shift a frame right what
do you think is happening in your brain
do you think your brain says I'm lacking
the resources
oh well what should I do poor me I don't
have the time I don't have the money I
don't have the knowledge I don't have
the skills
I'm lacking so if your brain is a bio
computer which it is
right if your brain is a bio computer
which it is
if you're thinking and feeling like I
don't have the resources
isn't that the software that your brain
runs saying I don't have the resources
you feel like you don't have the
resources then therefore you don't take
action I want to give you a couple of
things to do starting right now are you
ready
instead of focusing on lack of resources
I want you to think of this how can I be
resourceful
[Music]
how can I be resourceful
right now
how can I be resourceful right now who
can help me with the resources that I
need now think about this for just a
moment I mentioned there's four areas
that we want to talk about
is your mindset one of your resources
that you could tap into okay what
separates the best from the rest is it
possible
that asking yourself better question
leads to better answers asking yourself
better questions leads to more empowered
emotions more empowered emotions
actually move you towards what you want
disempowering thoughts and emotions move
you away from what you want does that
make sense what has to happen in order
for me to that opens up the neural
networks of your brain that actually
causes you to use your brain the best
way possible but when okay we are
focusing on a lack of resources where
we're focusing on negative thoughts
negative feelings negative emotions
negative results negative everything in
our life we're lacking something whereas
when we open up our brain we open up the
world of possibilities and your
biocomputer goes to work so when we're
dealing with mindset you can become
resourceful you can go to my YouTube
channel you can go to my Instagram
Channel you can go to my Facebook videos
you can read my books you can read other
people's books other other people's
trainings as well you can join us on the
brain-a-thon and we'll upgrade your mat
mindset so that you can elevate your
abilities does that make sense number
one it's not the lack of resources it's
in many times the lack of your
resourcefulness and it's the lack of
answering or asking yourself empowering
questions that will move you forward and
towards your goals versus okay versus
moving you away from we are creatures of
habit so we repeat these patterns over
and over again but first we have to
start with using our brain better you
already own a hundred billion dollar
brain you already own it you don't owe
anybody a penny on it it's yours so you
need to start using your brain better so
we want to become resourceful okay with
our mindset skills to upgrade it so then
all right finding resources for mindset
I just gave you that what about skill
set so now okay
um you know I don't have the skill set
right so you can be focused I don't have
a skill set I don't know how to earn
more money I don't know how to manage my
money better I don't know how to invest
properly I don't know how to protect my
money I don't know how to get out of
debt faster I don't know how to use debt
as leverage I don't know so if you are
in that state of mind of I don't know
around the skill set you are hostage
you're Hostage to that and let's get you
unstuck let's get you to stop standing
on the edge of potential how to make
more money I don't care if you have a
job or you don't have a job I don't care
if you have a business if you committed
to 30 minutes a day to upgrade your
skills
could you make more money
like 30 minutes a day okay every day for
365 days right it's like 190 hours of
training
190 hours of training if you just
focused on making more money for 30
minutes a day
okay that's the equivalent of four and a
half
weeks of training four and a half weeks
of training that's nine that's four and
a half nine or 40 hour weeks right 180
hours so it's not the resources called
skills that's your issue
chances are it's you're not committed to
upgrading the skill set to match the
goals and dreams you want would you
agree let's be real be radically honest
don't yourself okay tell
yourself the truth if I was committed to
30 minutes a day I could learn how to
make more money if I was committed okay
I could learn how to manage my money
better if I was committed I could learn
how to invest a lot better than I know
if I was committed I can get rid of my
death a lot faster if I was committed I
could actually use debt
in order to make money if you can borrow
money at two or three or four percent
you can make ten percent you can make
the spread all those are skills and if
you are not being resourceful with
either your time your focus your energy
then guess what you're going to be a
victim of your current circumstances
this is the truth no here so
we've talked about mindset we've talked
about skill set I've given you an entire
uh recap of this whole week now here is
there are two more sections to this
action set mindset plus skill set plus
action set so
are there people who know what to do
many people know one or two or three
things they know what to do but they're
not doing it but that comes back in to
mindset which is what the brainathon is
all about but action said if you don't
know what
every day every week every month every
quarter every year if you don't know if
you don't have rituals for Success
whether it's Financial Health you know
wealth relations career or business if
you don't have okay a an action set
rituals that start every morning that
guarantee and create predictability then
your action set the set of actions you
take may just not be the right action
set so to be able to know what to do
every single day your action set right
there's no such thing as time management
the only thing we can do
the only thing we can do is manage what
we do in time and there are some people
that are highly highly highly productive
and focusing on the critical few things
that get the big great results and
there's other people that are focused on
the trivial many without an
organizational action set of what it is
they should be doing
right so when we're talking about you
know getting the mindset right that's
part of it but you've got to have the
skill set but you also have to have the
action set right also this is like a
formula no differently than if you want
to solve the Rubik's Cube there's an
algorithm if you want to open up a lock
you know to a safe that has a million
dollars in there there's a combination
this is the combination I'm giving you
and then number four
is your environment the first
environment that I've just been talking
with you about all week is your inner
environment right the inner environment
but what about your outer environment
are you involved with a group okay of
people that lift you up are you involved
okay in daily inspiration are you
involved with people that can that can
help promote you can help lift you up
can help you solve challenges can help
you you know achieve your goals faster
or are you in an environment where your
people are bringing you down and you
might be the one lifting them up so when
we're talking about uh Resort resource
of becoming resourceful you have to get
yourself into an environment okay that
lifts you up
right that lifts you up that causes you
all right to challenge yourself that
causes you to let go of your stories
your reasons your excuses fast and gives
you the ability to step into your
greatness so when you do that all right
now you are putting yourself in the
environment internally with mindset
skill set action set and the environment
that lifts you up as you climb you lift
others up all right so
when we do this we give ourselves the
best chance we are now uh finding the
resources okay and being resourceful
okay for mindset for skill set for
Action set and our environment
five grand is a doable deal how do I do
it it's 412 dollars a month
okay I gotta go steal the money I can
steal five thousand you could steal five
grand for me and I wouldn't even know
it's gonna be like
if you could add 5000 to that and earn
twenty percent it'll be worth a million
125. if you could do this at 10 and be
worth 320. some of you small thinkers
out there be like dude I'll take the
320. how do I get 10 and how do I get
20. you guys have figured this out
you're like
if the play is big enough dude I'll
figure that out everybody agree see what
I just I shifted your mind by giving you
a Target
I don't go to Target I get targets and I
keep targets and I refresh the Target
and the target is I want to be a
millionaire but over the period of time
I got 20 years by the way what would pay
me 20 a year over 20 years
and that is when your boy GC
got rich
I didn't get rich speaking I didn't get
rich selling books
I got rich shopping real estate
30 years old shopping every weekend dude
every weekend all I did between 25 and
30 years old was make money make money
make money and push it aside push it
aside push it aside even when in the
first years when I was not watch this
even when I was not
25 years old five grand boom next year
five grand
boom next year five grand boom guess
what next year oh by the way this
money's sitting dead in the bank
it's not not only anything it's it's in
a it's in a holy account
holy means okay I'm gonna put a hole in
your face if you're touching my money
nobody could get this money this is not
like sacred account okay you with me 28
oh wow man I could add a little bit
maybe there's more money 29. what am I
doing right here okay one two three four
boom I got twenty five thousand dollars
sitting in an account
it wasn't a million dollars and I'm five
years into the plan
but when I was ready to start investing
money I started doing my homework 30
years old
homework
shopping properties 31 homework shopping
properties 32 I'm not buying cars you
guys are buying cars flying on jet
Charters showing off going on vacations
all I'm doing is stacking paper guess
what happens I have five years of
putting five grand away next thing you
know I had twenty five thousand dollars
to add to my twenty five thousand
dollars next year I'm making more money
I got twenty five thousand dollars you
see what I'm doing I'm stacking dough
and looking for twenty percent
I know there's a 20 play out there some
of this money was sitting in the bank
this is years and years ago where the
bank would pay me six or seven or eight
it didn't matter that's not the target
the target is to get to 1 million
remember this and let's open up the
calls okay your job is to find a vehicle
that can pay you 20 a year might be a
business might be the business you're in
it might be to buy advertising for the
business or brand you're in for me it
was this I'm going to buy real estate
that over long periods of time I will
earn cash flow okay it's how the real
estate works
I put 25 000 in a deal
that deal is probably going to pay me 10
a year
you said yeah but Grant you said would
you say Grant would you say
20 man that's what you said yeah I know
what I said this ain't Eddie okay now
how much do I have I could reinvest that
money back in the deal the next year I
have 27 000
500.
[Music]
I earned 10 on that
it has 27.50 or something like that
I reinvest that now got 30 000 in the
deal
okay but what you don't know is the the
rent on this property as I own it over
20 years
2038 will dispose of this thing the rent
is going up as I'm adding money the
rent's going up and maybe this goes from
10 percent a year
by the time I sell I want to be at 20
okay my average deal has paid me over 30
percent a year
[Music]
so when you start taking money and start
compounding it like that for long
periods of time the trick is long
periods of time the tax department which
every country has taxes determined they
want to know what kind of income do you
work for
So when you say to someone your age or a
child to the parent a parent to the
child
they say it's go to school get a job
they're working for this type of income
earned income
as you can see from this diagram here
this is earned income here and the first
thing you pay is the highest taxes
because you worked for money
yeah the government doesn't want you
working for money they punish you for
that they want you to hire employees or
invest
earned income is what they work for the
second
is portfolio income it's also called
capital gains so if I buy a house for
let's say a hundred thousand I sell it
for two hundred thousand the hundred
thousand is capital gains if I buy a
stock for ten dollars and sell it for
twenty the ten dollars of the capital
gains this is the second highest text so
the tax breaks that President Trump is
working on today is primarily for these
guys here
so they're doctors lawyers
Highly Educated people and they have
stocks
most of these guys don't have stocks of
the working class they have a 401k
but they don't get the break
but these guys if you're active in
stocks and that kind of stuff of
flipping houses you get a break
but with the really which work for
is
passive income and passive income
[Applause]
for May I have a business whether I work
or not money comes in
and you've seen me I'm not here am I no
I never never
I've earned the right not to be here
real estate I get military every year my
wife and I can we add more real estate
also we have commodity income from oil
wells and things like this even the
stock price of oil doesn't go up and
down and all this we still look at this
but this is another type of income
this here I'll get into is called
Phantom income it's taxes I don't pay so
there's a little bit beyond most
people's minds but let's say my tax bill
is a hundred thousand dollars
by doing what the government wants here
the government may give me a fifty
thousand dollar tax break that means
fifty thousand in taxes I don't have to
pay
[Music]
so the fifty thousand dollars it didn't
go to the government it went back up
here
so that's what Financial education does
it teaches you about the financial
statement which is not taught in school
again they teach you FICO scores which
is really Fido scores
you told little doggy okay
and then for you at your age now you
want to know this this is what they're
teaching you to work for now ironically
when you save money Ava 401k
this is the kind of income so Savings in
401ks are taxed the highest types of
income
to me it's stupid but if you don't know
any better it's the saving money in
what he called it 401 cases good in this
in Canada it's called rrsp in Australia
called the superannuation
but
this is what most people
have because they went to school they
got a job
and then this is what the rich really
have it's passive
and it's because
I'm an active investor I don't buy this
because this is passive investors
I am active and I'm professional in all
of these areas
so I work for passive income which means
I'm not here
the check comes in the checks come in
every year and you've seen Kim and I and
your mother now
she's working on here and so your
mother's income keeps going up your
father's income keeps going up and they
don't have a job let's say you have a
fear of
public speaking
is it really a fear of public speaking
that you have or is it a fear of getting
up on stage and being embarrassed
ashamed ridiculed or judged
hmm let me take you to another type of
fear
being buried alive can you imagine for
just a moment if there was an earthquake
or there was a natural disaster and
somehow you were buried alive
wouldn't that trigger this crazy amount
of fear of dying while you were buried
alive now why am I taking you there I'm
taking you there because fear is a
subconscious trigger whenever we feel
threatened and the threat could be a
threat for our very lives and when that
happens we move into one of four
modalities and modality number one is we
try to fight this feeling number two is
we freeze because we're in such shock
number three we may faint because of the
neurochemistry that the fear causes or
we might run away if we can run away now
these neurological reactions are our
brain's way of keeping us safe which is
the highest need and desire of the brain
safety above all else so when we are
looking to achieve a goal that we want
to achieve and it doesn't matter if it's
you know to start a business or grow
your business or leave a relationship
that you're not happy in or a job that
you're miserable in
whenever we think about the actual
behavior that is required to achieve
that goal
once we get motivated in doing that
that's part one of how our brain works
but right after that our brain has to
analyze if there's any real or imagined
danger associated with taking that
action step so if you are going to leave
a relationship that you're not happy in
your brain is going to activate the
memory circuits and discover what's in
there that may have caused you pain and
suffering in the past and when that
happens whether it's a relationship you
want to leave a job that you want to
leave a goal you want to achieve your
brain is always analyzing is there any
danger here and when there is real or
imagined Danger
the amygdala part of the brain the
emotional response Center in the brain
is going to fire off an amazing amount
of neurochemicals like cortisol
epinephrine or norepinephrine and it's
that Rush of those neurochemicals that
causes this emotion energy in motion we
label as fear now once you have that
Rush of neurochemicals in your
bloodstream that actually gives you an
enormous amount of energy
but what most people never have learned
how to do is how to take that energy and
channel it to action versus the fighting
it freezing or running away when you
recognize a fear I want you to do this
it's called inner size number one it's
called take six calm the circuits when
fear neurochemicals are released in your
brain you've activated the fear or
stress response Center in the brain when
you just observe
the emotion called fear through being
quiet and breathing six times in through
your nose and out through your mouth
like this you take a deep breath in for
five seconds
[Music]
you blow out like you're blowing out
through a straw and if you do this five
seconds in five seconds out five seconds
in five seconds out with six to ten
breaths
you're going to deactivate the fear
response Center and that actually is
going to reactivate your thinking Center
in your brain so that you can move on to
Inner size number two inner size number
one is take six calm the circuits inner
size number two is called Aya a i a and
that stands for awareness intention
action so here's how you do this after
you do the first inner size then you
move to Inner size number two and then
you ask yourself in a calm relaxed state
what am I thinking right now what am I
feeling right now am I calm or am I
tense am I breathing deeply or shallow
is my heartbeat fast or slow and in this
state of calm awareness
as you deactivate the brain's fear or
stress response you can observe
what you are feeling and what you are
thinking and what you were doing and
then
you can ask self the next question that
is the I what is my intention right now
is my intention to move forward or is my
intention to stay in this fearful State
and chances are you gonna say well I
really want to move forward
and then you ask yourself what is one
action step that I can take
to move forward towards my goal and
dream so this is how it works after you
do the inner size number one to calm the
circuits and to deactivate the reactive
state that fear causes and then you move
into the second inner size called Ayah
to move into the responsive State
awareness intention action now puts you
in control of being aware of the fear
being aware okay of what you've been
thinking and then being at choice of
what you want to do so when you combine
these two inner sizes you are now
reconfiguring the neural network in your
brain around the goal that you want to
achieve and instead of allowing the real
or imagined danger to control you and to
stop you dead on your tracks you take
one action step in a calm State and that
rewires your brain so that the same
reaction action doesn't hold you back
anymore and that you are now able to use
fear as your fuel for Success what is
Max out really stand for for you and
when did that moment happen where you
knew that that was gonna be part of your
brand yeah
um my son's name is Max so that helped
um but maxed out to me means this as you
know your obsessions become your
possessions whatever you end up being
obsessed with you'll eventually possess
so if you're obsessed with what you're
worried about your fears your problems
you're going to possess those and so I
became obsessed
um the the short version is is that you
don't know this I don't talk about this
on camera very much when I was 30 my
uncle died at 50 years old and he was
the guy in my family we all have this
that you kind of resemble or remind
everybody of my dad's brother he died at
50. sorry no thank you I appreciate that
it's a long time ago now and um but he
was kind of was my godfather and or my
culture that's a big deal of course
might as well yeah I know yeah Uncle
Mike yeah mine was Uncle Mike
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa everywhere
right there whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa
Whoa man that's how the universe works
right
wow okay
you got me right there so mine was my
Uncle Mike
wow
and oh man I just touched me
so
mine was my Uncle Mike and uh that blows
my mind right there brother
so
I'm on I'm at his funeral we're flying
back on the flight there's this thing in
your brain called the reticular
activating system it basically filters
into your awareness what's important to
you that's why like if you buy a new car
all of a sudden you see that car
everywhere on the freeway three lanes
over on the other side another one they
were always there why do you see them
now it's filtered into your importance
and heart attacks were at my he had died
of a heart attack and so I'm on the
airplane and I'm listening to music and
on the screens the Oprah show but I'm
it's in my awareness and it's a heart on
the screen I'm like
unplug my headphones plug it into the
phone system and it was about a new
heart scan that was happening at Cedar
signing where they could like it's
common now but they could not evasively
look at your heart and your arteries
long story short I hear it and I told my
wife I said schedule me for one of those
exams she's like it's expensive I said I
don't care schedule it we call it's a
nine month wait I go I need to get in I
need to get in I keep calling the lady
finally she goes there's a cancellation
tomorrow at two I go I'll be there so I
go down for the scan and thank God this
doctor understood influence and leverage
do you do the scan then you come back
after lunch I literally went ate a
burrito
came back I wasn't in shape I'm 30 years
old the doctor comes out and he goes um
no I'm looking for Edward mylet I go
it's mylette you know and he goes uh he
knew and he goes
well I can't believe these arteries are
in that younger body wow you need to
come back son
now my heart's racing I'm like what the
hell's in the skin we sit down instead
of what a normal doctor would do they
just go hey um here's the prescription
take Crestor work out eat goodbye he
understood reasons is what changes
people's lives massive reasons not
disciplined reasons and habits right
because let me ask you a question your
wife's beautiful
um uh do you have kids I go yeah I go I
got a son he's one he goes That's great
um do you want to be there when he
graduates high school
I went what he goes do you want to be
there when he graduates high school I
said uh yeah he goes okay uh yeah she
pregnant I go yeah what does she have
and I said a girl you get to a dad this
is what you say he goes would you like
to walk that little girl down the island
or wedding day son
I went what what is in this scan dude
and he goes I want to be very clear with
you young man I remember this like
yesterday because I want to be very
clear with you young man
if you continue down the road you're
going another man's going to live with
your beautiful wife and your mansion
walk your son at graduation and he's
going to be arm in arm with your
daughter on her wedding day not you
you'll be long gone actually as I tell
you this right now dude right and he
goes what I'm going to get you to do is
I'm going to get you to max out your
life and your Fitness
and I went
get me yeah and he gave me exactly what
I needed to do and he said if you do
this you'll walk her down the aisle blah
blah blah from that day when I get up
like I did this morning and I'm tired
and I was late last night and I don't
want to go to the gym I swear to you
brother I swear to you I go Bella's
wedding get your ass up and I go I I'm
fit because I have massive reasons
that's why I'm fit and that started the
journey towards maxing out every area of
my life I'm like if I can do this in my
fitness I can do this in business I can
do this in my spirituality and
everything I'm not going to shortchange
myself by pretty good I'm going to see
what my real potential is what my
maximum capacity is every single day
because at the end of my life when I do
die I have this belief that when I'm
done the Lord's going to go well done
good and faithful servant and by the way
here's the man you could have been this
is the man you were born to be this is
the man you were destined to be this is
where you could have gone but you could
have seen the memories you could have
had the people you could have helped the
person you could have become and meet
him my obsession is that every day I'm
chasing that dude so that when I do die
we meet we're identical twins because
the bad end of a life whether it would
be at 30 50 or 150 would be I meet that
guy and we're total strangers yeah so
I'm obsessed with meeting that guy
someday and that's what maxing out means
my dad did a style of martial arts
called Kyoko shinkai
and um and I suppose this little boy
trying to get close to Dad I was like
well if he's doing it I'm going to join
him so my dad and I shared this
incredible passion of martial arts and
cars right
um
so I kind of get started you know with
my father then he gets gunned down when
I'm 13 years old and I went through like
a year of just nothing I just I couldn't
show up at the dojo I didn't have it in
me
and I did all the things we're talking
about the excuses at the time South
Africa had a a particularly high crime
problem and I was like you know what's
the point you know here's a first degree
black belt who gets attacked he get
takes nine bullets and he's dead anyway
why am I going to this thing called the
dojo right
again excuse is valid it really is
but there's no progress so a year
nothing
and then and then I was like I actually
miss it so I went back
it was interesting when I went back it
wasn't the same I wasn't doing the Qatar
to impress the senseis anymore
I was doing the Qatar because I wanted
every single movement
to be as close to Flawless as I could
get it
it changed my entire perspective so
and one of the things that happened
you're going to love this I'm literally
getting chills thinking about it one of
the things that happened is time
just expanded
so because we have a very finite
construct of time I'm going to be at the
dojo for an hour
but what happened was that our big felt
like five hours and sometimes 30 minutes
felt like five all of a sudden this
fixed construct of time you know it
started to change because my
relationship with what I was doing
changed so it wasn't just a punch it
wasn't just the cutter I wasn't just I
wasn't just showing up for the emotion I
was embedded in every single part of the
process I was looking for growth for
Progress right I have to tell you that
changed my entire life
so anytime I find myself stuck now
I'm I recognize that they're often the
reason I'm stuck is because I'm focusing
on the output and I'm not focusing on my
input right so output I've got to raise
100 million Rand for my business output
I've got to get 300 growth for you know
in customers output I've got to get 25
yeah that's all output
but what you got to focus on is input
what are the things I've got to do and
how do I do those things intentionally
deliberately and try to get better every
single time every meeting every impact
conversation with one of my staff
members every engagement with a client
or a potential client every single one
of those things how do I focus on that
moment because actually the output is a
sum total of how those things come about
so when you when you are at the dojo and
you are being graded and you are going
through the process of trying to attain
your black belt or your brown belt
that's what everybody sees is the output
but what actually went in was that
malleable construct of time where you're
trying to perfect every single movement
in that year when I was really broke and
I was really broken I was working at La
Unified School District
I was miserable
I was miserable because I wasn't living
in my dream I was just doing a j-o-b and
then one day
I said well what what do I need to do I
I need to I need to buy my freedom
so I need to do I need to buy my freedom
well I don't know about buying my
freedom I don't know about buying I
don't know about having money saved up
my family didn't have money saved up my
mother used to tell me oh this money is
burning my pocket so I know two things
about money it's hot
and we can't keep it long we'd always
have one week where we had all the food
in the refrigerator and then one week
where we were the refrigerator was empty
right come on come on some of you guys
know about that to this day I spend so
much money on groceries you guys oh my
God it's like I'm feeding like a family
of ten because I'm so afraid of anybody
ever being in my house and being hungry
right
and so I I wrote a check to myself
Jelani was three
hundred and ten dollars
took it to the bank
Wells Fargo
started a new account
the next check I wrote
125 dollars
and just like the first check I put in
the memo line funding my dream I wasn't
even clear what the dream was
but I knew there was something in my
belly who in this room know you got
something in your belly it's something
I'm not even clear about it I don't know
how clear you are but I wasn't clear
about it but I knew there was a calling
on my life greater than working for La
Unified School District and no
disrespect to La Unified School drink it
just wasn't my destiny
I wrote another check in two weeks
146 dollars
funding my dream
now I started mailing the checks in
because I didn't want to see my balance
because I didn't want to go shopping
because I you're gonna repeat what you
learned right until you decide to not
repeat what you've learned
so I mailed the check in and I wrote
another check and I wrote another check
and every check I wrote I made sure it
was five percent more than the first
check the net the previous check I sold
my Altima I had a car note sold my auto
bought a clunker because it didn't have
a car note now I can write a bigger
check funding my dream
I moved out of my three bedroom three
bath three bath house and moved in
became a roommate with my friend who
smoked I put towels at the base of the
door so the smoke wouldn't come to the
door I was willing to be inconvenienced
are you yes yes I'm just saying I'm just
I'm just showing you the story I just
the charge I just gave you I stopped
getting my hair done that was when I
started going natural I stopped going
out
I I stopped going out dancing I stopped
going out to dinners my family didn't
know what was going on they thought oh
my God you know it was La she's on drugs
but she's not losing weight so maybe not
I don't know what's going on
I kept writing bigger checks to myself
nine hundred dollars nine hundred
dollars
I mailed it to Wells Fargo funding my
dream
eleven hundred dollars
mailed it to Wells Fargo funding my
dream I still wasn't clear what the
dream was
I just knew I had one
and it was being born through me
and I needed to give it a chance
that's all I knew
you don't have to see 2 000 feet in
front of you just see 200.
and run to the 200.
you'll have to see it all
three and a half years later I'd written
a check to myself every two weeks for
three and a half years
I didn't go out for three and a half
years I didn't go dancing I didn't get
my hair done I didn't get my nails done
for three and a half years are you
willing to be inconvenienced for your
conviction
I walk in to Wells Fargo three and a
half years later
and I said hi God bless you hi
my name is Lisa Nichols she goes oh my
gosh you're the fun in my dream lady I
was like
yeah I guess I am and all of a sudden
all the tellers came running around the
manager came they're like oh my God okay
oh my God we have been wondering we all
got the same question y'all know what
the question is right
what's your dream
I was like um
I'm not sure
but I know that it includes inspiring
people
having people believe in themselves
again
teaching them how to get back up when
they've been knocked down
get having to be willing to give
themselves a thousand Second Chances
and every time they get to 9.99 press
reset
I'm not sure what it's going to look
like but it's just gonna help people
I said I came to check my balance I've
been writing a few checks to you guys to
say yes you've been writing a lot
I said I just wanted to check my
balances you don't know your balance I
said no I got this really big stack of
summary bank statements at home because
my mama said money Burns her pockets and
I don't want it to burn my pocket I
wanted to pay for my freedom
I said I just came to see what my
balance was if I had enough to fund my
dream as it gets clear
she wrote it down everyone's excited she
wrote it down turned it around to me I
looked at it I said oh no my name is
Lisa Shantae Nichols and my social
security number I said that is not my
money and I am not taking that money
because you're probably gonna want it
back
so just fix that error right now
and they looked at me
they said you really don't think that's
yours
I said no my family's never had five
thousand dollars in the bank or ten
thousand dollars in the bank
that's
sixty two thousand five hundred dollars
in the bank
they said Miss Nichols and everyone
teared up the manager teared up the
tellers teared up
they said Miss Nichols whatever your
dream is
I think you can fund it now
I looked at my son Jelani who now was
five or six and I said Jelani
our lives are gonna be a little
different now baby
Jelani said yeah
Mommy can we
can't we now go to McDonald's
see for three years I've been telling
Jelani I'll make you a Big Mac
Mama makes Big Macs better than
McDonald's
and so it began with a hundred and ten
dollar check
so I don't know what yours is I don't
know what your radical looks like
for some of you your radical was coming
here
right yes yes and this is the beginning
this is the beginning of your radical
this is the this is the bet the next
best step this is the first step and so
I just stopped by to let you know you're
on the right path
and and as you ramp up as you ramp up
you're going to have questions you're
going to be afraid I do more things
afraid now than I do Fearless
because the bigger you play the bigger
your breakdowns
every single one of my errors in the
last five years have cost me six figures
like every single one every single one
of my errors has required me to call an
attorney
[Laughter]
like they're just big because I'm
playing big
I'm playing big so be willing to go to
the edge
and this is where you are here
be willing
to go to the edge
and not just lean over
and feel the breeze
and watch the people jump
and watch them soar and look through the
windows at all the people who are living
great life don't just go to the edge and
feel it
be willing to lean
fill your heartbeat
feel it
that lets you know you're alive
to let you know you're okay
fear fuels you fear lets you know go get
more information fear lets you know step
a little later and study fear lets you
know get up a little earlier fear let
you know ask for help fear is informing
you it's not stopping you it's just
another emotion like love and compassion
and gratitude we just made it paralyze
us
see fear doesn't stop me fear informs me
and when you get intimately connected
with the fear I feel it and I'm moving
forward anyway I feel it and I'm gonna
love anyway I feel it and I'm going to
invest in me anyway I feel it and I'm
gonna show up and play anyway when you
get connected with fear it becomes your
best friend and when you stand on the
edge
oh
you feel the breeze
you feel the fear
and you leap anyway I think
entrepreneurs are going to solve every
problem I think whatever problem there
is in the world entrepreneurs are going
to be the ones to solve it and there's
definitely a place for government and
everything else but I just defaulted
thinking it's us it's entrepreneurs
we're going to do it we see a problem we
want to fix it be the change you want to
see in the world and and that's really
at the Crux of a successful business
when people ask me how do you make money
as an entrepreneur well you solve a
problem with something that you love
doing if you are solving somebody else's
problem that they're struggling with you
can get paid to do it and if you love
doing that thing then that's how you
start having a business right that can
have success long term sustainable if
you solve a problem but you don't love
doing it you're gonna end up burning out
phasing out people will be better than
you at it it won't be sustainable
because you don't love the thing and if
you just love the thing but you're not
solving a problem then you've got a
hobby right if you love doing something
but it doesn't solve anybody's problem
you've got a hobby and it could be
fulfilling and enriching for the soul
but that's not a business it's in that
combination of what solves a real
problem that you enjoy doing that's how
you start to make money I think one of
the biggest problems though for
entrepreneurs is we don't know what the
problem is we think we know what the
problem is but we don't know what the
problem is especially when it's for
ourselves we think that we know what our
problems are but we don't actually know
our problems because we're too in the
thing have you ever noticed that it's
easier to point out somebody else's
problems like you should be doing this
you know what's wrong with this business
they should be doing that but it's
harder to look at ourselves and say
Here's the biggest problem that I'm
facing right now at least I find this as
a challenge I'm sitting here at genius
Network this is a it's a what it's a
mastermind it's a success circle
of people who are
having seven eight nine figure
businesses and they meet once a month to
help each other out and one of my
favorite exercises is when you
basically go down and it's called hot
seat and you think about what your
biggest problem is and they put you in
groups and then you're explaining your
problem to the other people in your
group and you get suggestions you get
feedback and these are all you know
peers people who've done equally or
maybe even more things than you have and
it's great to get at least I think a
fresh perspective and so
yesterday one of the members that I was
in that group with he came up and he
said I my biggest problem is I need to
have more structure in my life I need to
be more intentional with my time I'm too
all over the place I'm I'm too you know
creative and and and I you know it's got
me this far but it's not going to be the
thing that gets me to the next step I
need to have more discipline and
schedule
and the first uh person started giving
him some advice and and she was telling
him how she sets her schedule and give
some feedback and
the thing they just kept throwing
flowing through my mind and when it came
to me to give advice I just asked the
question do you even want this
you know like do you even want this
and
he's like
it feels it sounds like prison
as a guy that you've been in prison
before so he knows what that feels like
he's like when I when I think about it
when I talk about it feels like I'm in
prison and that is
a classic case for a lot of
entrepreneurs who want freedom who are
creative who want to be out
like creativity is messy
activity is messy and so you can't be
productive and you can't be efficient if
you're being creative and knowing a
little bit about him said dude that
that's not your problem see this is
where we got cut up in our own in our
own traps and our own thinking because
we can't self-diagnose very well we
often need people to help us so when he
says
my problem is I'm not being intentional
enough with my time and I'm wasting a
lot of time I need to be more structured
that's not his problem
in fact what he needs to do is the exact
opposite he needs to be spending more
time in his own of Genius he needs to be
spending more time being creative he
needs to have the freedom to spend three
days swimming with alpacas if that's the
thing that is in his mind because it's
going to lead to some awesome new
creation that if you take a creative
genius like he is and you force him into
a structure and a schedule then he's
going to end up
in a prison like he said and and just
imagine you know if he lives a week like
that versus a month like that versus six
months like that versus a year like that
the more he's trapped in that prison the
less effective he's actually going to be
he might be really efficient and
productive
for a short amount of time but he's
gonna end up hating his life and he's
not going to birth any new uh creative
things into the world and he's out of
his own of Genius
and so
his real problem is he doesn't have the
person on his team to be that number two
to take things over
and he hasn't assigned that person the
responsibilities or given them
permission to be able to to run with
those things he's already built the
seven figure business so it's not like
I'm I'm talking to somebody who's brand
new startup doesn't know what he's doing
right this is a already successful
entrepreneur but again it's easy to spot
the problems in other people's
businesses and other people's lives and
sometimes in our own and so
the problem was different than the
problem that he thought he had
and solving the right Problem by getting
some perspective
will change his life just as I was
talking and expressing
what I thought about him you could see
that he starts to come alive and at the
end he's like I feel that and this is
the guy who's really in tune with with
body and energy and is like I feel that
he's like touching his heart you know as
he's doing it and like thank you and
what a gift and so
we solved the right problem
and so
if you are struggling right now
I think one of the best things you can
do is is one model success so go find
the people who've done what you're
trying to do and see what resonates you
know Bill Gates saved my business even
though I've never met him because I had
a software company and I looked at Bill
Gates who started a software company and
that's what I modeled and it started to
work
but I think even more importantly
if you're really struggling right now is
to be around other people who might be
able to help
because you're around some people even
if you're a shy and introverted like me
you sell people some people around you
the problem is they can't tell you what
the problem is you know their their
version of the problem is something you
don't want to hear I don't believe in
negative or toxic people I don't think
that's what's going on but they're
you know hurt people hurt people so they
could be in a lot of pain they could be
hurt they have a different perspective
one that you you don't want their life
you don't respect their opinion on the
thing that you're asking about and so
you just probably around the wrong
people
and to be able to change that to shift
that to you might be able to I mean this
group here one group was 25 000 a year
being the other's a hundred thousand
dollars to be in so
um you may not be able to afford to to
go to a group like that but you don't
need it because the most you don't need
it yet you know the most important thing
is momentum just start building to start
being around more positive optimistic
happy people who you do respect you can
do something with I made a group called
movement makers and every two weeks we
meet and these are people who want to be
thought leaders who want to share want
to help have a message on their heart
and need to get out to the world and
it's great to be around me and I teach
and I share and I give my perspective
but the biggest learning I think
honestly is by them being connected to
each other by them doing challenges and
projects together by them interviewing
each other on their channels so that
they're not alone and they have people
to talk to and connect with and feel
like
like this matters and there's some
momentum because whatever you want to do
the people around you don't understand
it right if you're an entrepreneur
you're a little bit crazy it's awesome
like high five I love you celebrate but
you're a little bit crazy and different
and the people around you don't
understand you and some people might
just be supportive just not know what to
tell you and other people might be
straight out negative and say stop doing
that be practical be realistic go get a
job go to school go X go live a safe
life and you don't want that life
and so you need to start being around
the people collect good people who
support you who cheer you on who believe
in you who say that you can do things
who still push you but in a positive
left and Way Forward as opposed to a
negative way down that makes you feel
like things are possible and so how do
you find those people well
you could join a group right I mean
genius network uh might be a fit for you
if you've got a big budget movement
makers might be a fit for you if you're
trying to be a thought leader but but
actively look for people actively look
for events and conferences and groups
even if it's a free meetup group at the
beginning like actively look to be
around
people who are close to you or online
groups that you can join but that are
around the same interests of you because
when you're around the people who are
trying to do the same thing that you are
trying to do even if they haven't quite
done it yet it's not only mentoring
where they've done it and they're
showing you the ropes even if it's
they're trying to do it and you're
trying to do it to be around people who
are ambitious who want to chase down
their dream and goals and Achieve
something right and make something of
their lives if you're around those
people it will just fill you with more
energy
it will fill you with more energy and
make you feel like hope is possible
that'd be my median action item to yes
have the environment pay attention to
who you subscribe to on YouTube and who
you follow on Instagram and the books
that you're reading and the content
you're consuming does it lift you up
does it make you feel better and belief
and give you hope and strategies and
tactics on what to actually do and look
at your circle
you know you're with the right people
and if not then just don't don't don't
make it some big thing that you have to
go join this giant group that's super
expensive
just start with
who can I who can I talk to right now
you know who's trying to do this thing
with me too
who's even at my level
that I can build and grow and learn with
and if you just switch your mindset to
start to look to start the search to go
to Google and type in your city and look
for groups or to think about the
industry you want to be in like how to
be a thought leader or how to be a XYZ
whatever it is that you are in whatever
your business is and the fine groups of
people who are doing it you know you
want to be a Toastmasters for speakers
or whatever it is there's a group
to just join and try it because man when
you're around people who are doing
things
it just breathes so much more Life
Energy and momentum into your mission
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to turn your passion into a
successful business check the video
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there to build a happy little
Consulting business you can do it that's
the path is already there it's easy you
know people have done it a lot of people
actually at half a million it's enough
it's like a lot of people their ambition
actually really slows down when they hit
that half a million half a million